in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Aaron
and DD are with us hey guys how are you
hello welcome welcome where you guys
from Baltimore Maryland fine well
welcome to Nashville yeah thank you good
to have you and you're here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir how much have
you paid off a total of about three
hundred and twenty six thousand dollars
whoa
how long did that take six full years
Wow and making what kind of income
during that time well that's kind of a
story actually Dave we started out at
about 80,000 together working before we
had children and took your class and
both lost our jobs within four months oh
my gosh so yeah it was quite an ordeal
for that yeah so um and then we I guess
that was like 30,000 down there and and
then we're able to work up to errands
and sales and so just with a lot of I'm
like yeah well with perseverance and
with the teaching and what you guys
share we were just a typical story we've
ever done you got your jobs back yeah we
we started careers after we read the 48
days the working love book or I did and
II was able to stay home and we've
earned about 200 the last couple years
oh my goodness okay okay so the 326 is
that your house and everything yes sir
you paid off your house we did Wow very
cool so how much of the 326 was your
home about 200 okay
yeah very cool good for you guys
excellent so 126 what kind of debt was
that so the rest of it was being stupid
upon stupid so if you can name you know
from credit cards to time chairs not one
cars credit cards and student loans
that's it yeah very cool well good for
you guys an excellent job very well done
okay who's the young man this is Elliot
our firstborn ah and Olivia's around
here with a friend
very cool very cool good so you got all
these high schoolers standing here
watching you there's a whole high school
class that's taking our curriculum
that's joining us on a field trip so
they're getting to see you guys what
it's like to pay off a hundred and
twenty six thousand dollars with a
stupid and then turn around pay off your
house too that's it
so way to go you guys excellent so what
advice do you have to someone is deeply
in debt what are the keys to getting out
of debt yeah well we have the blessing
and privilege of being able to
facilitate financial peace at our church
and you know just walking with everyone
kind of through the same things that we
went through and I saw we still think
like the most important thing that that
that we still do is doing our budget on
paper every month so we have our Budget
Committee meetings and and sit down and
that was really hard at first but but I
but I still think that it's one of the
that kind of gives you the cutting edge
to feel like you know knowing ahead of
time where your dollars are going yeah
that's a big deal
well congratulations your yeah very very
well done all right what advice have you
got for these high school students don't
go into all the debt we did listen you
know I I didn't understand much about
personal finances never really talked
about budgeting before even though I'm
the nerd and so what we decided to do
once we once we took your class was just
get as much good information in her head
as we could and that's what did it we
kept listening to the radio we started
you know to take financial peace class
and and just continuing to make those
inputs really made a difference if
finally something clicked yeah and we
felt like we were on a different
trajectory so it does change everything
there's a is amazing that what happens
when truth intersects your life it does
change the trajectory that's it in David
it's probably worth mentioning that you
have a gentleman here that runs your
financial wellness program and smart
dollar we've just brought that over to
our company but Bryan Hamilton
actually introduced our FPU coordinators
oh wow yep John and Sarah Thompkins back
to Baltimore okay and we are so grateful
for for all of these people because they
in sharing that truth gave us the
opportunity to get out of dad and really
change change our lives completely so
how old are you - I turned 33 tomorrow
and DD something like that might be 20
by now yeah yeah alright and you so a
hundred percent debt-free house and
everything making two hundred a year
man you got a blast ahead of you this is
getting on be able to give so much
you're gonna be able to do so much for
your family congratulations it works
very very well done alright count it
down Aaron MD D can we wait for my
little girl to come over can you still
bring her real quickly yeah he said
count it down so it's been waiting for
this moment
Elliot's ready yeah we're gonna hear
maybe we can we can lean down real quick
I think Olivia is going to come in and
join us
alright ready
that scream as loud as you can three two
one
job you guys well done well done